vanessa
foreign
good evening members and welcome to this
extraordinary full council meeting on uh
today tuesday the 18th of january i'm
councillor mark hurd chairman of the
council
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for kovi
therefore and i ask all present to work
to the protocols agreed on by the
council on the 2nd of september 2021 in
the interest of member and officer
safety
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
at the meeting you are giving your
consent to being recorded
members and officers during each each
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please reference a
page or paragraph number when referring
to the agenda papers keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible and remain seated
we are live stream sound recording this
meeting and this is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
i ask when you are invited to speak
please remember to turn your microphone
on and off when finished
please can you also avoid approaching
the top table in front of the cameras or
there are live feeds and they are
hazardous and affect our streaming
i'd like to draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is
the door behind this top table
uh members i'll also add that members
need to confine their participation to
matters relevant to any agenda item any
declaration of interest should be
limited to the declaration itself
it is inappropriate to use public
meetings to make allegations against
employees or other members
an official complaints procedure exists
to raise such allegations and these
procedures should be used and the
monitoring officers should be contacted
for further advice
any member that does not comply with
these requirements will be in breach of
my ruling i will warn them to desist and
if they persist i will either adjourn
the meeting or propose that the agenda
item should be dealt with without access
to the public under local government act
1972 schedule 12a
paragraph 1 and 2 and that such action
satisfies the public interest test if we
do go into private session the live link
will be cut and that member will have
denied the public having access to the
debate
and voting on that agenda item
i one other notice at the last council
meeting um it uh
i've been informed that there was some
cheering in the chamber by members over
a death threat
i would like to let people know that it
is not acceptable
that it is not acceptable under any
circumstances by any member
council
thank you german i would like it noted
that that cheering did not come from
independent group members
thank you chairman thank you what i can
say is i don't know who who it came from
but nevertheless i do not like to hear
in this chamber councilor morris
thank you mr chairman can i just ask did
you hear the cheering
no at the time i was conversing directly
with you so you didn't hear the cheering
did the monitoring officer hear the
cheering
anyway i've made that i've made that
statement and it is unacceptable
it is unacceptable and i'm a little bit
saddened at the top table uh denying
hearing it thank you
i'll move on now to agenda item two
apologies for absence um miss bird could
i have any apologies please
thank you very much
and councillor fleming as well i
understand i believe she's um i don't
know something with the family i believe
she's trying to may try and get here but
i i would doubt it i think you got the
email chairman i did yes thank you very
much
so gender item 3 members are
declarations of interest this is just to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members and members
are reminded they are also required to
disclose any such interests as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting
councillor mays
non-pecuniary
thank you non-pecuniary um declaration
in relation to item five i live in alton
thank you thank you very much council
stamp uh the normal chairman i don't i'm
a member of essex county council but i
can't see anything where they've been
consulted on tonight's agenda but just
to cover just in case chairman thank you
thank you very much
no other
declarations
okay
we move on now to
agenda item number four this is leaders
and composition of political groups
these are found on pages
five to eight
um
members i
have to tell you that i was informed by
councillor siddal earlier today that he
has asked me that he has stepped down as
leader designate
and as a result um i will be
uh
nominating councillor richard siddall as
leader of the council
do i have a second
proposed council
first of all i'll take i'll take um
councillor maize's seconder
point of order rule once the chairman
captain
councillor thompson
yes councillor voice
thank you chairman uh rule one
um
i think it's seven or eight um but it
deals with statutory annuals
unfortunately
the constitution
is quiet
on um the leader designate designation
but if we follow the same procedure
as the um
uh statutory annual the leader designate
if there is no leader designate
present tonight
then the leader designate should be the
leader of the next biggest party
which is mrs chana should be the leader
designer as as the independents our
leaders
yes thank you for that but this is not
an this is not a statutory annual it is
an extraordinary and obviously it is at
my discretion um to interpret the
constitution
so do i have any other nominations
well i i did hear councillor thompson
first councillor thompson
is that seconded
who is that seconded by please council
council beal thank you
any other nominations councillor stan
it's not a nomination nomination
chairman i just would like to ask why
if there if you're allowed to tell us
why the leader designate has resigned
it's my understanding he did
the same at the last one and i just
think it's very it would be helpful to
the members of the public as well as
some of the members here if we could
have some advice i'm sure it's above
board and it's legal and i don't know if
the monitoring officer can help but i
think um a full explanation is required
because i personally feel it is
playing games chairman and i i'm sorry
but that is how i've been okay thank you
for that i'll refer to the monitoring
officer
obviously i can't comment on whether
this is playing games or not that's for
members to decide
um
but uh if the leader does if council
siddal has resigned as leader of the
independent group
then he ceases to be leader designate
uh no ratification process can take
place because there is no leader
designate because the independent group
have not chosen anybody
to take his place that's my
understanding of the situation
um
so that
it then leaves it for
there to be
as the this is an agenda item and it is
an agenda item for the council to have a
leader of the council
that then leaves it open for the
chairman to ask for nominations in the
absence of a leader designate who at the
last moment has resigned from his
position
i hope that makes sense
thank you chair thank you mr quelch
thank you yesterday
well thank you chairman unlike what
counselor stamps just said that's got me
thinking and chairman i think you said
you heard earlier today that councillor
civil had resigned i'm rather surprised
the notification didn't go around to all
members to advise us of that chairman
because really as a council i think we
should have been and i'm now hearing
that it happened at the last meeting at
5 00 pm um i've just again chairman were
you advised of that and why weren't we
all told i think as members when
something like that happens
we do have a right to have to be made
aware of the situation because otherwise
it could be said others are advantaged
to other members if you've seen my if
you see where i'm coming from i'm very
surprised but i'm not having to go i'm
just saying i'm rather surprised that on
receipt of receiving that um perhaps
officers or your good self didn't let us
all know
okay that's noted thank you councillor
morris
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
say that what counselor channel has
described is exactly the behavior that
i've been receiving from this council no
one's getting my emails no one's allowed
to have my emails no one wants to uh
inform me about anything so uh
you know have some back
okay
um
so we have um
members we have um two candidates
what i propose to do is to uh is to put
that to the to the vote
um and it will be recorded vote please
vote please
is that second that's obviously seconded
okay
so the uh are you are you ready for that
um miss bird
so there are so it will be either
councillor channel
channel or councillor siddal
um if you could uh call the role please
sorry chairman sorry can i just carry 5.
are we what can when you're going around
are you asking us to give the name of
the person we're supporting or what
quite clearly yes yes right so he says
councillor civil or councillor channel
or civil law yeah just so it's clear
doing it that way so it's just so it's
clear members it's either council a
civil or councillor is that the right
way chairman to do that
there's someone knocking
yeah
all right we'll just start to find out
can we just have clarity so we're voting
for um cancer civil or councillor chana
at the same time so you're not doing
cancer ciddel yes no and then council
channel is that no i it will be just a
name
okay fair enough thanks whoever your
preference whoever your preference is
please
or abstain yeah
no okay all right
who can do abstain as well so it's chana
fiddle or abstain channel or abstain yes
please okay um
miss bird
thank you chairman uh starting the
council of bassinger please
councillor
are you canceling this bill
councillor channel
thank you councillor brian beal
councillor
councillor boyce
councillor chana
council mrs chunner
um well
make sure i say the right one councillor
channel
thank you
councillor
councillor channel
counselor mrs chan i thank you
thank you
heard
councillor siddall
councillor helm
councillor mrs channer
councillor hoovener
pennsylvanna
councillor hall
councillor keys
councilman mrs char
councillor lagan
councillor mrs channel
councillor morley
councillor mrs chennais
councilman morris sorry chairman maurice
councillor siddal of course
thank you councillor none
councillor mrs chandler
councillor
shaunity house
sorry no i didn't say anything i was
waiting thank you ladies
um councillor thank you
councillor siddall
councillor
thank you councillor schemes
councillor
councillor
councillor chana
councillor stevens
councillor siddall
this is stilts
councillor
councillor swain
oh sorry i couldn't see sorry i do
apologize
thank you chairman the results of that
are 15 for council mrs chana 13 for
councillor siddal and no abstentions
thank you
okay thank you in that case i i declare
um councillor penny channel as leader of
malden district council
thank you can i just say thank you very
much i'm very privileged and honored
thank you
right um
thank you for that members we now move
on to the election of the deputy leader
for the council um do i have a
nomination who's counsellor mrs thompson
chairman
councillor mrs thompson
and that is duly seconded who seconded
that please
counselor hoovna are there any other
nominations
no other nominations in that case in
that case i declare councillor mrs
thompson
as deputy leader
of malden district council
congratulations mrs trump
excuse me kevin thank you members
appreciate it
right members we move on then to agenda
item number five which is the langford
and ulting neighborhood plan
decision on examiner's report
and this is contained
on pages 9 to 80.
the purpose of this report
is to inform members
and seek their approval
to seek their approval for the
recommended
modifications made in the examiner's
report at appendix one for the langford
and alting neighborhood plan and to seek
members approval for the neighborhood
plan to proceed to referendum
the recommendations are that the
examiner's modifications be agreed
and that subject to these modifications
the neighborhood plan meets the basic
conditions and other legislative
requirements
two that the draft decision statement
attached at appendix to be approved to
be published on the council's website
and that the langford and alting
neighborhood plan be agreed as modified
at appendix 3 proceeds to a local
referendum based on the boundary of
langford and alting neighborhood area
as recommended by the examiner do i have
a seconder
councillor mays thank you
members i do have matt winslow who is
present on this report do we have any
questions or comments
councillor channel um
well can i just i know councillor
durham's not here tonight but i believe
he's one of the ward members for
langford and elting
and i know this has gone on a very um
long time this process and procedure and
indeed i've been involved some years
back with the villages so i'm sure we
will be told about the examiner's
modifications but i understand they're
ones that we actually need to agree
because it meets then the requirements
of what is required to go ahead if we
don't then that's a different scenario
so i'm sure councillor durham if he was
here in fact i know as much would
support this chairman so i just give
that information
thank you very much councillor fluker
thanks chairman
and
i think i said this last time but before
we vote on this
uh and i don't have any problems with
the recommendations i think it's right
sorry i can't hardly hear you cancer
fluke so chairman i understand that the
piece of legislation banning noise that
protests didn't go through the house of
lords so
i'll um i'll try and speak a bit louder
thank you chairman i i i said this last
time and i don't change my mind this
time
i really would like to pay tribute to
the people that put this plan together
because local place planning is very
very important it's going to be
fundamental and a core piece of
information within the new ldp as in the
new
mppf as it comes forward and i think we
really should thank these people and
also chairman encourage some of our
other parishes to come forward with with
local plans thank you chairman okay
thank you very much
any other
comments or questions by members
that's a stamp chairman could we please
shut that window and open a different
one because i can't
yeah if we can i'm sorry i'm sorry but
we can't hear you i know anybody else
all right okay if we could open those
please
oh no don't let bob die
thank you
well we'll leave we'll leave those uh
leave those open
i don't think it was a question it was
it was a comment um
yeah okay uh councillor stamp
was it chairman i'm sorry could you
repeat the question there wasn't a
question it was can we have the window
closed chairman see nobody can hear
anybody
all right thank you members thank you um
councillor bell was at the same point
same point thank you very much
okay members uh
uh can uh can we move would you like to
vote on this or can we agree by ascent
that is agreed thank you very much
we now move on to agenda item 6 which is
the council tax base 20 22 23 and this
is found on
pages 81-88
this is the setting of the council tax
base that's the number of houses on
which the resident's council tax is set
for 2022 23
any member who has council tax arrears
of more than two months you are reminded
that you must declare at this time and
you are not able to vote
do i have any declarations
i do not
the purpose of this report the council
is required to set the tax base for
council tax by the 31st of january in
the financial year preceding that to
which the tax base applies
the council has to notify its tax-based
calculations to essex county council
essex fire authority and the police and
crime commissioner for essex and parish
town councils by the 31st of january
the recommendation is that in accordance
with the local authorities calculation
of tax-based regulations 2012
the amount calculated by malden district
council as its council tax base for the
2022-23 year shall be set at 25 524
do i have a seconder
counselor maze thank you
members are there any comments or can we
agree this by a cent
thank you very much
we now move on to agenda item seven
vacancies on committees working groups
and outside bodies
these are found on pages 89 to 92 of
your pack three to six on the
supplementary and three to six on the
supplementary thank you okay
so we move then uh to this item and this
is to appoint vacancies associated with
councillor stephen nuns councillor kevin
leggins and councillor bob boyce recent
withdrawal from committees working
groups and outside bodies as well as the
resignation of councillor carl jarvis as
a district councillor
and i shall be taking each of the
recommendations in turn
number one that the council ratifies the
group nominations for committee
vacancies
set out in section 3.5
and
and appoints a member to fill the
non-aligned vacancies counselor channel
i've i have the uh i have the
recommendations here that uh that uh we
need two non-aligned members for pg a
okay i'll take those
[Music]
[Music]
are there any other nominations
oh sorry is that seconded
thank you any other nominations
in that case councillor stamp and
councillor fluka will become members of
the pg a
the next item
is strategy and resources
three non-aligned members councillor
um
councillor swain
thank you chairman yes i would like to
nominate councillors
um
none and um well i probably can't
nominate council stanford councillor
lagan and councillor nan for those two
two of those positions
[Music]
okay can i confirm can i confirm that
councillor nun and councillor lagan are
prepared to sit on that committee
uh yes chair and also councillor fluker
thank you very much is that seconded
thank you councillor who seconds that uh
so those three members will become
members of strategy and resources that's
councillor nunn councillor lagan and
councillor fluker
we have one nomination for the joint
standards committee and that is one
conservative do i have a nomination
counselor channel
yes chairman obviously i nominate
councillor mrs thompson but there is
another vacancy
which um has to go to a non-aligned and
has to be an unaligned so i'm proposing
council helm so my nomination is
councillor mrs thompson is the
conservative nomination and council helm
is a non-aligned and i'm happy to
nominate councillor helm chairman thank
you
are there any other nominated councillor
fluker
all right oh thank you that's saying any
other nominations
in that case in that case i declare
that counselor oh councillor morris
sorry
if i couldn't speak after
you've finished let's check okay
so joint standards committee uh one
conservative uh which is councillor mrs
thompson and one non-aligned member
counselor helm is that agreed by assent
thank you council morris
thank you um
as you may be aware i've left the
chamber because there is considerable
outrage
the members of the public
are being um kept out of a public
meeting in a public building
and probably their public money is is
being given to private security to keep
them out of this meeting
i've gone down to speak
i was wondering if there's anything we
can do at all to accommodate
any members of the public that are
respectful because obviously as a chair
you have the power to remove members of
the public that
might cause a scene
to save all what's going on downstairs
is there any um
is there any way that we can get
respectful members of the public to view
this meeting at the back there okay i do
have a view on that but i'll take
councillor fluker's point
jeff and i i i think the in a roundabout
way i think councilman moyes makes a
good a good point i mean we've got you
know the democratic process has to be
seen to be taking place
um
this meeting has almost come to its end
tonight but chairman i wouldn't propose
that they come in this evening because a
decision has already been made
but chairman i really do think you need
to visit this with the monitoring
officer and the officers to see if
there's any way that we can accommodate
these people at future meetings any
members of the public not just these
people and and chairman i also want you
to take note of what council morris said
because clearly you do have the power to
eject people from this chamber if you
need to thank you yes um i'm i'm mindful
i'm mindful first in the first instance
about the number of people in this room
but i will take advice from the
monitoring officer
um
do you want me to give a view now yes if
you could yes
and it's my understanding is that this
council made a decision
in relation to the safety of
everybody employees members and the
public
because of the present crisis with covet
my understanding was a resolution was
made
that
really it can only be members and even
many employees are not attending simply
because of that they are attending
remotely
um
now that's a resolution of council
council would have to change that
resolution
um
of course council can do that council is
sovereign um but at the moment that's
how mata stands and that is why
the count what is why we have security
staff down there now can i just say two
things here a second thing here as well
the council also has health and safety
responsibilities as well the local
government act 1972 with the access to
public does
give the right for members of the public
to attend but also
the council has
public health duties health and safety
duties as well and the guidance from the
government is very clear
about restricting numbers and only
essential people being
in meetings of this nature
so if the council were to let the public
in then there is an issue
of the council satisfying its health and
safety responsibilities
public health responsibilities this
isn't simply as i understand it the
council resolving
that they didn't want the public in this
is the council resolving to protect
people's health and well-being now
members can change that of course they
can and that's a matter for you as
members but that is why we are in the
present situation
councilor morris you want to come back
on that thank you mr chairman um firstly
uh a legal maxim that uh mr crouch
should be aware of is that consent
removes error
we are acting ultra virus by not
allowing the public into a public
meeting to watch the democratic process
there is more chance of someone getting
crushed down there than killed in here
from omnicron
we have residents they are residents
outside they are not protesters
they are asking to exercise their
democratic rights to watch
what's going on we have empty seats at
the back
and we should allow the people
to come in and watch what's going on
they can see it online
yeah
okay um
my view is that if members of the public
wish to see this meeting
it is being broadcast on youtube
um
council morris thank you councillord
not everyone's got the internet
these people are here
and like we need to be here physically
they have a right to be here physically
as well
this looks like we are trying to keep
business closed
when that is not the look the council
should have yet again i reiterate the
point it is their democratic right to
witness the democratic process we cannot
keep the public out of a public meeting
in a public building
i i hear what you're saying but i think
on the grounds of advice by the
monitoring officer and through the
health and safety
on this occasion i am going to keep this
meeting
with this number of people in i'm
concerned as it is
with the number of people in this room
let's come back once more
thank you
thank you chairman well
i'll be leaving the meeting because i've
got a lot more in common with the people
out there than the people in here i'm
here for the residents
yeah and we are acting ultra virus by
stopping them coming in because it is
their democratic right to see the
democrat process thank you very much
well that's that's a matter it is a
matter for you
that's a fluke so kevin i i made a
request early on that you would visit
this with the monitoring officer and
perhaps even councilman mice but i think
that needs to be done well in advance in
the next meeting we know we know that
the direction of travel regarding covert
regulations is changing we know that's
going to change at the end of the month
so i think we need to do that rather
than open up another debate
uh at our next meeting yes only to say
that we are going to facilitate people
come to these meetings so i i hope
that's a yes that you will meet them
councillor fluker and um just so
knows i did send i sent several emails
around that none of you appear to have
got
um
asking for this sort of thing to be
sorted and it hasn't been all right so
the sooner we sit down and we'll talk
the better can i can i just um
again refer to the monitoring officer um
about a procedural matter mr crouch yeah
of course
of course members are entitled to put in
a notice of motion
the council procedure rules allow that
so if there's any member or several
members that feel
that
they want to see the public now and
matters are safer
then a notice of motion can be put in
for the next council meeting and members
can vote on that particular issue
as matters stand it is the resolution of
the council that's controlling this
um and so likewise members can
reconsider the matter and reach a
different conclusion but
notice of motion procedure is open rule
four of the council procedure rules
permits
that gentleman can i can i uh ask a
question uh probably of the monetary
officer but nevertheless three years is
i know we're all keen to get away
because this could be one of our
quickest meetings for a long time but is
there any reason why we can't debate
this tonight
and and basically say basically formally
well it's not on the agenda and to start
well no but i think you could chairman
you you told us earlier on i think to
counsel the boys that you can make a
decision and we know you can but my
biggest concern here is is if we if
someone brings forward a notice of
motion
um and it's only partially agreed or not
agreed at all and we have a lot of
people outside in with the hope value
that they'll be allowed in and they're
not that's not fair to them
so i i
ask you to try and think of another way
to do this so that we can be in a
position to facilitate them at our next
meeting rather than discuss emotion uh
and not know what the outcome of that is
jim and and i i i'd like to think that
you know we we could propose a motion
tonight which allows hugo to go away and
sort it out in time for the next meet
mr chairman thank you very much
would it be possible to have a large
television screen outside so people can
view outside
like they do with football matches and
similar they can see exactly what's
going on
well i think in fairness they can see
that from home
well i know that i'm just saying if
they're outside would it be possible to
put a large screen
all right
um
yes council appeal thank you chairman um
i'm under the uh
impression that this has all been
through the covered and government
restrictions and everything else sorry i
can't but i'm sure that all of the
measures are actually going to be
greatly reduced this thursday when the
government look at it again after their
three-week period and i think that will
sort this problem out
because we won't be limited to x amount
of people etc and as you say it is being
streamed on youtube it is yeah yeah
um
yes councillor fluker
was i was going to say i don't think
we've we've done all the committees yet
but bearing in mind the the uh what's
going on outside can i propose chairman
that we deal with the committees yes
let's call this meeting to an end yes
all right have another meeting lots more
um move on to the next business which is
this and keep going on this sorry cancer
channel i can't that's exactly what i
was going to say could we get on with
this business yes yes yes
i'm all for that right so the last thing
was the joint standards committee one
conservative
i think yeah
i'm just i'm just just
just saying okay so councillor mrs
thompson and uh councillor helm is for
the uh the the jsc so investigating and
disciplinary panel one non-aligned
member councillor channel councillor
lagan i propose council of lagoon
chairman
that seconded any other nominations
councillor lagan are you happy to serve
on that
i am very happy thank you very much
thank you very much uh councillor lagan
then uh will be on the investigating and
disciplinary committee panel
e investigating and disciplinary
committee
one non-aligned member councillor
channel i would like to nominate
councillor stephen
paul but none sorry none sorry
sorry i'm thinking of the farm shopping
awful
all right
thanks matt thank you members councillor
channel
i propose councillor none for the
investigating and disciplinary committee
are you happy to serve i am sure thank
you
uh in that case i i declare that oh are
we happy to agree that by saying
okay not for me to declare
and finally
f licensing one non-aligned member
councillor channel
sorry chairman i'd like to nominate
please counsel a voice for licensing
committee chairman please is that
seconded councillor fluke ii did that
any other nominations
uh in that case councillor boyce will go
on to licensing thank you
yes
i'm just going on to uh
pgna i think i've got those later aren't
they
pga you've had yeah yeah
right okay uh so i'm going to move on
for nominations for the performance
governance
audit
uh do i have two nominations you've done
that chairman i did that at the
beginning yeah yes there we are
uh
licensing right okay
right so we then move on to um
the recommendations that the council
appoints or ratifies a member
representative for each of the outside
body vacancies set out in section
3.9 um do i have a seconder
councillor maize
uh i shall read them out action for
family carers
is councillor shaughnessy
blackwater estuary siltation group
councillor mays
brad will be community forum councillor
miss white
civilian and military partnership board
councillor bruce hubner
essex flood partnership board councillor
miss s white with councillor c swain as
substitute
f malden high street focus group
councillor jay keys
south end airport consultative committee
councillor schemes
stonemarie's aerodrome consultative
committee
councillor fleming and
miss s white
councillor white also there is
liaison council will be councillor brian
beal
right are you happy to agree those by
sentiment
thank you very much
the third recommendation is that the
council appoints or ratifies a member
representative for each of the working
group vacancies set out in section
313 and the requirement for two
nominations
for corporate governance working group
and the leisure contract task and finish
working group
i would like to nominate from the chair
councillor michael edwards for both
corporate governance working group and
leisure contract task and finish working
group do i have a secondary
council amaze
can i can i make proposals please i'd
like to nominate for the corporate
governance working group council of
boyce and for the leisure contract task
and finish um vacancy council and none i
got it right that time council enough
sorry who is the first one councillor
boyce for the vacancy on the corporate
governance working group yes and for the
leisure contract task and finish working
group where there's a vacancy in
addition to councillor swain i'd like to
propose and nominate therefore
councillor stephen nunn he was on it
chairman and for consistency i think it
would be a good thing for him to be on
there
councillor um edwards
um are you prepared to give way for
those nominations
you are okay um in that case then uh it
will be councillor boyce
for the corporate governance working
group and councillor nun for the leisure
contract task and finish working group
do i have a secondar
councillor fluker thank you
uh
is that agreed members
thank you
uh
right uh could i thank councillor
edwards please through you for
giving way generous giving way i
appreciate that i don't know which way a
vote would have gone but it has saved us
the agony and i greatly appreciate it as
i'm sure we all do
sorry
okay thank you very much
we need to remove your first proposal
we proposed counsellor and i think he's
already said no hasn't he he's basically
moved aside yeah he's moved aside on
that
well i'm being told that no that we have
no it's not necessarily
it's not necessarily no i'll go with
that okay
uh
so the uh
the working groups will be as follows
air quality management area member
working group councillor stilts
brad will be power station working group
councillor durham
corporate governance working group
councillor edwards
boyce councillor boyd
all right okay councillor boyce
uh corporate plan task and finish
working group counselor swain
finance member working group counselor
chana
and the leisure contract task and finish
working group counsellor none
with councillors wayne who is already on
and councillor swain yeah
are we happy to agree those by cent
members
thank you
agenda item number eight uh members i
thank you and officers for your
contributions this evening i will now
draw the meeting to a close at 2017.
as the meeting is closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion in this forum and to please
leave the meeting promptly keeping in
mind social distancing requirements
thank you
you